je me suis demandée en fait quand tu
aurélie ne m'a contacté en quoi j'étais
légitime pour pouvoir intervenir dans un
ted parce que va comme tout bon c'est le
tête c'est partager une idée avec
potentiellement la terre entière en tout
cas avec vous ce soir
et puis j'ai discuté avec l'origine avec
magali j'ai vite compris que c'était du
fait de mon expertise sur les serious
games voilà si vous googleliser valérie
boudier service bien vous tomber sur moi
tomber sur des articles vous tombez sur
mes conférences sur mon ouvrage
alors ça c'est bien sauf que me voilà
collet maintenant à ce terme serious
game en français jeu sérieux puis je
vous avoue que moi ça me fait pas trop
rêver d'être collé à ça c'est une espèce
de demi-mesure moi je suis pas trop
dansé dans la demi mesure on va jouer
pour être sérieux va quand même s'amuser
et aura quand même à prendre
bon le fait est que maintenant c'est
comme ça qu'on les appelle
on va regarder ce que dit notre ami big
ip via sur le jeu sérieux un jeu sérieux
c'est un logiciel qui combine une
intention sérieuse de type pédagogique
avec des ressorts ludiques
en fait là on n'enfonce un peu une porte
ouverte on va jouer en apprenant et je
n'avais pas vu qu'on avait il ya
peut-être le thème logiciel qu'on a
droit de retenir si on continue de
manière synthétique un jeu sérieux
englobe tous les jeux vidéo qui s'écarte
du seul divertissement
moi j'entends jeux vidéo ça m'interpelle
par contre on n'a pas le droit de faire
que du divertissement
bon alors excusez moi
je vous montre cela et ça c'est un
joueur de jeux vidéo
vous avez tous peut-être souhaité des
moeurs soit assisté à des personnes qui
jouent aux jeux vidéo
hélas hélas l'enseignante que je suis
qui s'interroge j'ai enseigné au collège
j'ai enseigné au lycée j'ai enseigné à
l'université je peux vous garantir que
pendant toutes ses années d'enseignement
j'ai jamais réussi à avoir de la part de
mes élèves
le niveau de concentration que je vois
chez les joueurs donc pas question c'est
pas de savoir s'il se divertissent il
s'amuse si c'est sérieux c'est pas ça la
question qu'on doit se poser en tant
qu'enseignant on doit se demander qu'est
ce qu'il sait faire le jeu vidéo qu'un
enseignant ne sait pas ne peut pas faire
elle est la nôtre question alors c'est
vrai ils vont jouer des nuits entières
et ça fait peur mais c'est pourtant ça
qu'il faut qu'on observe faut savoir ce
que le jeu est capable de déclencher
comment il est capable de tenir cet
engagement ce niveau de concentration
pendant des nuits entières donc oui ce
soir je vais être impertinente peut-être
osé de ma communauté mais je vous emmène
sur le terrain du jeu vidéo vrai jeu
sawicki ambitieux gène celui qui qui
nous envoûte à celui qui a dicté ifs et
puis vous allez voir il ya peut-être pas
plus sérieux que le jeu vidéo
alors j'ai écrit avec mon associé yves
dambach
un ouvrage qui s'appelle serious games
révolution pédagogique vous allez me
dire ma fallait écrire fallait
l'intitulé jeu vidéo révolution
pédagogique bob j'aurais dû en fait
c'est vraiment de ça dont je parle dans
cet ouvrage est en fait ce que je ce que
je mets en avant
j'ai des pistes en fait pour
révolutionner complètement l'acte
d'apprentissage alors pourquoi
pour faire face en fait à cette mutation
sans précédent à laquelle nous assistons
tous de manière consciente ou
inconsciente mais elle est là d'accord
en fait le constat c'est que tous les
individus aujourd'hui sont
potentiellement connecter tous entre eux
autour de la planète comme ça on le sait
deuxième constat c'est que l'information
est produite en quantité phénoménale
tous les jours de manière exponentielle
et donc nous sommes tous confrontés
un flux dix noms continuent cependant à
flux continu de données
donc nous devons apprendre tous à
travailler à avancer dans nos vies
privées nos vies personnelles dans nos
vies professionnelles aussi et a
affronté en fait ces flux de données qui
ne s'interrompt jamais donc le défi est
là et ma question est où sont les outils
pour nous apprendre à travailler ou même
à devenir dans ce flux ininterrompu de
données dans cette tourmente numérique
alors évidemment on a des salles de
classe il n'y a pas de plus dans la
salle de classe sur des modèles
statiques mais entend pallier vous
m'entendez mieux les salles de classe
sont des modèles statiques avec des
enseignants nous sommes tous
effectivement un peu statique dans nos
salles de classe les élèves sont
statiques
donc je pense qu'on n'est plus dans des
formats suffisant en tout cas pour gérer
ces flux de données et de la même
manière il faut il faut on nous a
proposé des moûts possible et moux et
des profs qui postent des vidéos en
ligne alors il ya peut-être une
exception regarder la communauté des
apprenants des mook mais je pense qu'on
n'a pas vraiment la solution
alors en fait ma quête elle elles datent
pas d'hier elle date en fait du moment
où j'ai eu je faisais ma recherche dans
les années 90 et puis surtout du moment
où je suis devenue maman
donc j'ai des enfants qui sont nés entre
1992 et 2000 donc des enfants qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui les jeunes de la
génération y alors on aime le nom
l'aiment pas peu importe ce que je sais
moi c'est qu'en tant que maman bas comme
la plupart des mamans du monde fallu
accompagner les devoirs s'ennuyait pas
mal quand même c'était compliqué le le
crayon le papier et donc j'avais acheté
la collection des adibou je sais pas si
vous connaissez un hibou ça rappelle des
choses à a dit vous a dit bout'chou y en
a qui chantent
bienvenue dans le monde a dit bout donc
il y avait des bouts d'choux pour les
tout petits à 10 pour les grands et puis
et puis voilà a dit bush était un petit
un petit extra terreste adorable qui
vous en est
sous la terre dans les mers et puis
c'était l'occasion d'apprendre bien
évidemment à lire à compter et puis
découvert plein de choses dans mes
enfants il adorait adibou c'est vrai que
c'était s'était parfaitement fait c'est
vraiment du ludo pédagogique pour le
coup sauf que la digue où il avait quand
même un ennemi qu'il exerçait un pouvoir
d'attraction exceptionnelle sur mes
enfants la game boy la game boy posé sur
le lit sous l'oreiller partout et puis
dans la game boy
les pokémon pikachu des racailles ou des
à la meije des carapuce elle avait plein
les pokémon feu des pokémon ou des
pokemon glace c'était compliqué tout ça
il adorait et c'était un raz-de-marée
tous les enfants du monde jouée au
pokémon
alors évidemment on peut faire comme
toutes les mamans les papas dans ces
cas-là on confisque la game boy
j'ai un peu confisqué la game boy ce
qu'on veut faire aussi c'est de
comprendre qu'est ce qui les attire dans
ces pokémon c'est quoi cette histoire de
pokémon j'ai regardé puis j'ai compris
en fait les pokémon c'est simple faut
les attraper tous sur la à peu près 150
à attraper je crois qu'aujourd'hui on a
plus de 350 60 des pokémon à plein alors
faut les attraper mais les attraper
c'est pas simple parce qu'ils ont tous
des cartes en fait des des
caractéristiques des types ils ont leurs
forces leurs faiblesses
ils ont des statistiques data qu'ils
évoluent en plus un donc un pokémon en
devient un autre et autant de pokémon
autant de caractéristiques différentes
donc en fait quand vous devez attraper
un pokémon faut le connaître connaître
les caractéristiques de votre propre
pokémon et mais des stratégies de
bataille en place pour réussir à
l'attraper puis des fois on rate et ça
ça tournait j'ai tous les enfants et moi
je me suis interrogé je me suis dit mais
c'est génial en fait les pokémon moi
j'aurais bien aimé avoir le pokémon
petit et encore une fois en prenant du
recul je me suis dit mais qu'est ce que
c'est les pokémon en fait c'est un
formidable terrain de jeux pour les
enfants et surtout ça leur propose de
s'entraîner à la complexité
voilà c'était jamais noir ou blanc dans
les pokémon c'était toujours quelque
chose de très complexe et compliqué donc
c'est un enfant de 7 ans 8 ans il avait
intégré des bases de données énormes des
flux de données incroyable et jouer avec
tout ça est vraiment apprendre 150
pokémon n'était pas un problème
et tous les parents disaient oui ils
n'arrivent pas à prendre les aides
d'histoire géo et les tables de
multiplication mais les 150 pokémon et
bah oui
voilà il y avait un jeu derrière il y
avait quelque chose de chouette moi j'ai
laissé entrer effectivement non
seulement les pokémon à la maison puis
pas mal de jolis jeux en fait qu'on
l'accompagné tout
toutes ces années donc je vous en cite
quelques uns parce que peut-être
certains gamer les connaissent donc le
monde de zelda toute la série des sims
et x on est très très beau jeu de
construction
la collection des total war ici on fire
total war qui avait été quand même
félicité par les professeurs
d'histoire-géo à l'époque donc des très
beaux jeux de stratégie et puis ce jeu
aussi que j'ai jamais trouvé incroyable
pro cycling manager alors j'ai pas du
tout une accro du cyclisme à mais là
encore les joueurs de ce jeu là qu'ils
peuvent avoir 12 ans ou 50 ans 1
là on fait pas de différence mais qui
sont à la tête d'une équipe de champions
cyclistes pour tous encore leurs
caractéristiques leurs forces leurs
faiblesses leurs humeurs et encore une
fois des bases de données incroyable à
intégrer non seulement le niveau de vos
champions
le niveau des champions des équipes
adverses les les courses que vous allez
affronter la course sur laquelle votre
sponsor vous attend qu'il faut pas rater
parce que de la défendre les budgets
enfin bon je ne vais pas plus loin dans
ce dans ce jeu mais encore une fois je
regardais ces jeunes de 10 12 ans il
faisait de la gestion de projet les et
la gestion de ressources humaines les
visas mène du management à peu tâté le
leadership parce qu'il fallait s'assurer
que les jauges de former d'humeur était
bonne et c'est franchement c'était
c'était c'était assez impressionnant
vous avez toujours et ce qui m'a encore
plus interpellé là encore en tant
qu'enseignante c'est quand j'ai
découvert que à l'extérieur du jeu dans
l'espace collaboratif les joueurs
s'échanger des bases de données qui
étaient plus optimisée par rapport aux
bases officiel du jeu donc en fait
quelque part quand on lit ça c'est les
élèves la communauté des élèves qui
dépasse le professeur donc c'est
vraiment super intéressant je crois
qu'il faut le regarder très très près et
donc ben fort de toutes ces années de
d'abord de d'observation des yeux des
jeux pardon de travail avec les game
designers j'ai beaucoup travaillé et il
discutait avec des game designers
déployer des jeux aussi sur le marché de
la formation professionnelle fort de
tout ça je suis arrivé à trouver
quelques pistes
deux solutions à ma question de tout à
l'heure qui était qu'est ce qu'il sait
faire le jeu vidéo que moi enseignante
je n'arrive pas à faire dans les salles
de classe alors une des pistes est bien
là probablement d'autres je pense que
les gamers qui sont plongés là dedans
depuis des années en ont probablement
d'autres mais moi la réponse que je peux
vous apporter c'est qu'en fait les jeux
vidéo plonge les joueurs dans des
situations complexes et quelle que soit
la situation
une situation de guerre ou une situation
de davanture de kate
le joueur doit se sortir de cette
situation déjà il ya des missions il ya
des quêtes
il ya des engagements du joueur et
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
informatiquement parlant se sortir de
cette situation
c'est là où ça devient vraiment
intéressant c'est qu'en fait le joueur
il craque des algorithmes de game
designer les game designers ont design
et ont élaboré des algorithmes très
complexe et craquer ses algorithmes veut
dire je passe au niveau d'après et je
gagne il est chaque succès et succès est
un algorithme craquer donc pour craquer
cet algorithme
qu'est-ce qu'il faut mettre en place
intellectuellement donc là je suis
encore en train de me demander
intellectuellement qu'est ce qui se
passe dans la dans la tête de ses
joueurs développent des stratégies en
permanence donc ils anticipent ils
optimisent ils prennent des décisions
ils gèrent leur stress prennent des
risques aussi est plus important je
pense que le jeu en les stimulant
permanence les forces à libérer leurs
pensées créatives en fait les forces a
inventé en permanence donc un joueur est
en permanence en train de libérer sa
pensée créative qui est un point très
important donc imaginé cette énergie
lorsqu'elle est démultiplié dans un jeu
multijoueur c'est à dire que là les
jouets les joueurs entre eux doivent
ajuster leurs représentations
pourquoi opéré partager à l'intérieur du
jeu et en plus à l'extérieur du jeu donc
dans ces espaces collaboratifs
ils partagent ils inventent il imagine
ensemble c'est phénoménal
on n'a pas le droit de s'interdire de
regarder ça avec un nouveau regard qui
peut gêner effectivement il faut le
regarder de très près alors je pense que
certains d'entre vous c'est en train de
se dire voilà c'est une douce rêveuse
c'est possible peut-être que je rêve un
petit peu et ma foi c'est pas grave mais
c'est vrai que j'aime bien imaginer en
fait la puissance d'une intelligence
collective qui réunit ray des joueurs du
monde entier ses joueurs réunis ray leur
créativité dans un jeu qui serait
objective et sur les grands problèmes de
notre monde
pas de problèmes sociétaux des problèmes
environnementaux des problèmes
politiques économiques je sais pas mais
moi je me dis que peut-être vous
retrouverez des belles solutions pour
pour pour résoudre les problèmes de
notre monde
un dernier hommage à mes enfants gamer
et j'ai à toute la communauté des gamers
en fait du monde et j'en remercie de
votre attention